YOSSI FARJOUN: This is
Dr. MATLAB, Lecture 1--
Using MATLAB for the First Time.
When you turn MATLAB
on for the first time,
you'll be greeted with a
window that looks like this.
The first thing we do
is close all the windows
that we don't need initially--
Current Directory, Workspace,
and Command History.
We're left with
a command window.
This is the command prompt.
And this is the flashing cursor
where our input will be placed.
The first thing we
want to do is try using
MATLAB as a giant calculator.
So for example, we can ask
MATLAB to calculate 1 plus 1.
The answer is 2.
So we type what
we want, 3 plus 4.
Hit Enter and we
get the answer--
3 times 4, 1 plus 2 times
3, 2 to the power of 4,
5 to the power of 3, et cetera.
We can also ask whether
two numbers are the same,
or whether one is
greater than the other.
So to see if 4 is greater
than 5, we type this.
This will tell us
that the answer
is no, 4 is not greater than 5.
We can ask is 4 less than 5.
The answer is yes,
4 is less than 5.
Sometimes we need a function
and expression, not just
an operator.
So for example, to
find the remainder,
we need to use the function rem.
Here is the remainder of
15 when divided by 4--
rem(15,4).
The answer is 3.
To find out more
about a function,
we use the help command.
help rem will tell us everything
we need to know about rem--
the remainder after division.
There's a bit of an
explanation, some conventions.
And the "see also"--
this is perhaps one of the most
important parts of the help
file-- is to help you
find other commands that
are useful and related
to this command.
I encourage you to try to find
the difference between mod
and rem.
Other than calculating
expressions,
we can also assign their
value into variables.
So for example, if I want to
create a variable named x,
I type x equals and then
the value that I want.
So for example, x=1 will create
a variable called x and put 1
as the value into it.
I can also put the result of
an expression into a variable.
Here's y=2*3.
Of course, that's 6.
So it calculates the 6 and
puts 2 times 3 into it.
So now y is 6 and x is 1.
And I can use x and y if
they are numbers. x+y,
the answer is 7.
If I try to use a variable
that doesn't yet exist,
for example z+y,
I get an error--
undefined function or variables.
Sometimes, you're
looking for a command
but you don't know the command.
You know that you're
looking for something,
bu you just don't know
what it's called in MATLAB.
In that case, you
should be using lookfor
to find the command
you're looking for.
So for example, lookfor
square will give you
all the commands that have the
word square in their help file.
Of course, I was looking for,
in this case, square root.
And here it is.
I can either click
on this and that
will give me the help
file of the square root.
Or I can just type help sqrt.
And that will give the same.
Square root finds the
square of the elements.
So if I do sqrt(4), I get 2.
Notice that I get
complex results
if I get a non-positive input.
So sqrt(-3) is the square root
of three times i, which is,
of course, very nice to know.
So 2i^2 should give me -4, and
indeed, 2i squared gives me -4.
On the command line,
there is a useful trick
involving the "up" button.
Sometimes, you're
looking for something
or you're typing something and
you make a typo, like this.
I've swapped the
L and the E. Now
I could retype
everything from scratch,
or I can press the up key--
up arrow-- and then the left
arrow until I can delete the E,
and put it in the right place.
Now when I hit Enter
and I get the help info.
With the up arrow
and the down arrow,
I can browse through the history
of all the commands that I did.
If I have a longish
expression on the command line
and I want to erase
the whole thing,
I could start erasing it.
Or I could press Control-C.
That's probably
enough for today.
To exit MATLAB, I either
look for the Quit MATLAB here
or I can Apple-Q. Or from the
command line, I can type exit.